Before we get into our last module of a little workshop of just going through the packaging
process so we can all do it together, I just wanted to talk a little bit about packaging for
teams and especially for larger teams moving over to Unreal Engine, just talking about some
of the automation process and build processes that you can include as part of your pipeline.
So we have an Unreal Engine automation tool, you'll see it references UAT a lot of the
times and the automation tool enables you to cook and package your game using command lines. So
throughout this whole course we've been talking about cooking and packaging our game directly
through the editor, but there is an automation tool that's outside the editor that you can use
to run command lines and batch files. The files can be found in the engine build batch file
location and depending on if you are running Windows or Mac or Linux you'll be using
a different file structure there. So the automation tool is definitely recommended
if you are looking to automate your build process in Unreal Engine and we have included
the documentation link at the bottom here for you to explore that further. As I mentioned
on a previous slide, command lines are supported so basic cook can be performed using the
following command line arguments which are written down here. Just note that the command
line must be specified via the dash run equals cook and a platform to cook must be specified. So
as I've got an example below there just make sure you're following that file structure and
again any of the command line arguments that you can use in Unreal Engine are linked at the
bottom here. As I mentioned we wanted to break down exactly what happens when you click package
project and all of these different stages are documented on the Unreal Engine learn section so
if there's anything you really wanted to dig into here definitely go and research that but
as part of the build run in the automation tool we first have the build stage which compiles
the executables for the selected platform then as we've gone into detail on we then cook
which is executing the editor in a special mode then we stage the build so the stage copies
the executables and the content to a staging area which is a standalone directory outside
of the development directory then we package which packages the project into the platform's
native distribution format so again when we're talking about cooking and packaging the
content here it needs to be deployed whether it's for you know a pc or console or anything
along those lines then we're deploying the build to the target platform and then we can run the
package build on that target platform so we're going through this build cook run process in the
automation tool. I've also got the Unreal build tool which is the UBT for short which is a custom
tool that manages a process of building the source code across different configurations
you can definitely check out the cs file to explore the different build options
and of course link the documentation below if that is something you'd like to look into.
Unreal game sync is a very handy tool for teams working in unreal engine so if there's multiple
developers on the project it really helps promote the code and content collaboration
in the development environment and it's just a nice graphical front end for teams using
unreal engine to use just to note this is using perforce so you can optionally build those
projects using Microsoft visual studio compiler. I'll dig into game sync more in the next slide
but again just to highlight the documentation is below there for UGS and the reason why UGS is
good for teams working in Unreal engine because programmers as part of their workflow they'll
be you know syncing the project files with the repository they'll you know resolve any
conflicts and update engine version files they'll generate the project files and maybe build the
code in ue5 and then run the project whereas you know if you're an artist or a visual developer
or someone not needing to worry about you know merging conflicts and generating project files
you you just want to sync your files and make sure that you know that all the files are up
to date and that you can run the the correct version of the unreal project so UGS can kind
of skip that for a lot of artists and other developers on the project so you just taking a
bit of time to investigate UGS might be worthwhile for you know multiple collaborators on a project
and again it has that nice graphical interface that is just a very developer friendly environment
to work in. Horde is also becoming the kind of main powerhouse behind build automation and it's
what Epic uses to develop Fortnite and other unreal engine projects it does combine some of
the tools that we've already spoken about but it's you know a brand new architecture
that's aimed for centralizing some of the processes in this cooking and packaging and
managing content so previously where these different tools have been separately developed
Horde aims to integrate the whole process here so Horde you know it has the remote execution
using the UBA which we had mentioned it still does the build automation working with
Perforce repositories you can do the test automation which is integrated either with
the automation tool or gauntlet which I have linked documentation to about what gauntlet is
I believe it's not officially supported by unreal engine it's kind of a tool used internally
but you know the information and code is there for it to be used if developers want to do that
good thing about Horde is that it also uses the studio analytics which can receive telemetry
from unreal and also uses the unreal game sync which I mentioned in the previous slide with
teams working in unreal engine also has the console device manager as well as mobile I
should say which you know helps managing the final development kits and mobile devices so
this really helps centralize all the different processes that you need in the team so
Horde is definitely worth checking out and worth reading the documentation of it's also just
worth noting as we close out this section here that there was a great talk at the unreal fest
2024 about how to set up the studio using unreal engine the epic way and yeah I just highly
recommend watching that talk and just getting an idea about how you might want to set up
your processes in the studio especially if you're new to unreal engine